now the mayor of Kiev says the city's
air defenses have shot down multiple
Russian drones officials there say two
administrative buildings have been
damaged while Russia has destroyed much
of Ukraine's energy facilities causing
rolling blackouts as winter sets in well
for more on this let's speak to Rory
challenge he joins me now live from Kiev
Rory people must be anxious they're
hearing all these blasts over the city
absolutely it's been an unpleasant
wake-up call for Kiev this morning about
three and a half hours ago the air raid
sirens come on came on now I have to
confess I didn't hear those what I did
hear was half an hour later an enormous
explosion that reverberated around the
city center uh it got me out of bed
looking out the window couldn't see
anything but what we know is that it was
just one of several drones that came in
to the city I think the success rate has
been pretty much 100 in in shooting
those down so what we think is that the
Drone explosion that I heard was a drone
being shot out of the sky and coming
down and detonating uh on the ground but
not causing a huge amount of damage
there has been uh some pictures that
I've seen of smoke coming from an
administrative building not too far away
from here just a a kilometer or so away
and so some other damage to residential
buildings on the outskirts of the city
also pictures that I've seen of debris
on the floor a bit of a a one of these
Iranian drones the Shah heads with
Russian writing on it saying zap riazan
as that means four and riazan is the
location of one of the Russian air bases
uh that there were explosions at uh in
the last week or so and it hasn't been
officially confirmed by the ukrainians
but the Russians have said that those
were Ukrainian drone strikes on these
military airfields military airfields
that the Russians have been using to
send up their uh their big long range
bombers and hit Ukraine repeatedly with
cruise missiles yeah not a pleasant
morning I have to say in Kiev today
indeed well speaking of unpleasant when
I checked just a few minutes ago Rory it
was What minus four degrees Celsius in
Kiev how is everyone there holding up
with all the power shortages
well it's tough I mean the the situation
is gradually being uh regulated uh and
improved so there is more stable power
now but still these regular uh blackouts
which you know part of the day you kind
of organize your day around them if you
know they're coming a lot of them are
scheduled so you know that you're gonna
have power from say 10 in the morning to
midday so that's when you do all your
charging and uh and make sure that you
take a shower and you can use the power
to to its best Advantage but you know
apart from that most people are living
in dark cold uh uh possibly damp
Apartments uh or houses it's not a fun
way to live at all but I would say that
morale is not being dented by this
everyone is determined they've got to
carry on they're asking of course the
ukrainians for help from outside for uh
the the means to repair the energy grid
and also the means to defend the cities
from further attacks air defenses is one
of the key messages that you're hearing
from Ukrainian officials that's what we
need and the recent reports from America
suggest that this Patriot air defense
system which the ukrainians have been
calling for for some time looks to be
imminent uh it's not been confirmed yet
but looks to be imminent now it's not a
one-size-fits-all solution air defense
you need to have Laird approaches
different uh platforms different systems
for different targets and drones have to
say Patriot is not particularly a debt
for us more for bigger targets like
cruise missiles and ballistic missiles
something like a geopard which is a
German system big cannons on it that
rapid fire that's better for taking down
drones but yeah you need lots of
different types of air defense to tackle
lots of different types of targets
indeed Rory challenge there on the
ground for us in a very chilly cave
thanks so much Rory